-Today is Friday. That's usually
when I catch up
on some personal stuff.
I check my inbox and return
some emails and, of course,
I send out thank-you notes.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Wow.
-I was running
a bit behind today.
-Today?
-Today. I was very busy.
-What are you doing?
-Today?
-Yeah.
-Oh, man.
Well, I went to the skate park.
[ Laughter ]
-Of course. Well,
that's usually every Friday.
-Yeah, every Friday. Because
I'm working on some new tricks.
-Yeah.
What do you got going?
-I got like a 180 French roll.
-Oh, a French roll? Oh.
-Yeah, I'm working on that.
-Yeah?
-It's pretty cool, yeah.
Kickflip type of jam.
-Yeah.
-Jam.
-I say "jahm" because that's --
-Oh, you say "jahm"
because you're cool, right?
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I am cool, yeah,
but, also,
I learned to skate in Europe.
-Really? Where at?
[ Laughter ]
-And that's how we say jam.
-You just say "jahm"?
-"Jahm." What's your "jahm"?
-Really?!
-Yeah, and it's cool, but,
anyway, so I did that
and then I got, you know,
a matching tattoo.
-What'd you -- Who --
You got a matching tattoo?
-Of your --
-Of me?
-No, of your matching tattoo.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, oh, right.
The one that says,
"I love lasagna."
[ Laughter ]
It's Garfield.
-No, I didn't get that one.
I got the other one.
-Did you get the one
that said --
[ Laughter ]
-No, no, no. That was more --
-Not the racy one?
-No, I got your back tattoo.
-Oh, oh, oh, of course.
-Yeah. Spuds MacKenzie.
-Yeah.
-And underneath that, it says,
"Party animal,"
but spelled wrong.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
No, I got "Pug life"
on the front of my --
-Oh, nice.
With a little baby pug
and your bellybutton's
his butthole.
-Yeah.
-That's so cute.
[ Laughter ]
-Mouth, mouth.
-Mouth.
I'm sorry, mouth.
-Guys, can I write out my weekly
thank-you notes right now?
Is that cool?
James, can I get --
[ Cheering and applause ]
James, can I get some thank-you
note writing music, please?
-[ Playing tender tune ]
-He's always in a good mood.
-Summertime James.
-Yeah.
-Wow.
-Summertime James.
Takes his tie right off.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-He's like, "It's Friday.
It's Saturday somewhere,"
is what he says.
-Every day is Saturday for him.
-Yeah. He doesn't care.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, SPF 15,
for being the nonfat,
dairy-free oat milk
of the sunscreen world.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Doesn't really do anything.
It's fine.
-Yeah.
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you,
Wendy's new Strawberry Frosty...
[ Laughter ]
for showing us what it
would look like
if Jimmy Neutron dyed his hair
pink and hid inside a cup.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
-[ As Neutron ]
Where am I?
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
What?
-I'm just thinking about who I'm
going to write
this thank-you note to.
-Who are you going
to write it to? Because you're
making them up as you go.
-That's correct.
-Because you live in a state
of gratitude, yeah.
-Yeah, they're not pre-written.
-No, not at all.
-And I'm not reading them
from here.
-No!
[ Laughter ]
-I'm writing them right now
-From your heart.
-and sending them out.
-Right. You mail them to people.
-That's correct.
Using the U.S. Postal Service.
-Yes. Yes.
-Here we go.
-Who's this one to?
♪♪
Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you, Cornhole...
-Okay.
-...for being a game
that sounds dirty,
but is really just
a good old-fashioned game
of tossing sacks
and penetrating holes.
[ Laughter, cheering,
applause, and hooting ]
-Wow!
Costs you extra if you lick it.
There you go, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Cornhole.
-That's correct.
-Yeah.
So is that to the makers
of Cornhole?
-What's that?
[ Laughter ]
Could be the maker
of the Cornhole.
Could be to the players
of Cornhole.
It's like letters to Santa.
-So, when you put it
in the mail,
does it just say Cornhole
and that's it
and you throw it in there?
[ Laughter ]
-No, it goes label-less
and just finds its way.
-Like letters to Santa.
-Like letters to Santa,
almost, yeah, yeah.
-Beautiful.
-You got a good heart,
Jimmy Fallon.
-What's that?
-You got a good heart.
-I got a --
I got a good heart?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you, leather jackets,
for making people look cool,
smell like a shoe,
and sound like a couch.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
-[ Creaking ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Creak ]
Thank you, weed whackers...
-Oh!
-...for sounding like
an old-school
anti-drug organization.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"No."
-Just say no.
-Whack that weed!
-And whack that weed
out of their hand,
is somebody offers it to you.
-Cornhole it!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Cornhole it!
[ Laughter ]
-That's what they yell
at the tournament.
-Yeah, the tournament
before they start the game.
-Yeah.
Everyone gets in there, ready.
Cornhole it!
-Yep.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, the new Disney+
series "Obi-Wan Kenobi,"
for being a sequel
to the prequels,
but a prequel to the sequels.
[ Laughter and applause ]
We don't know, yet,
if we're getting a sequel
to this prequel sequel
that's set before the requels,
but, if I spend any more time
thinking about this,
I'm going to need some ZzzQuil.
-No.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
-[ Clucking ]
[ Creaking ]
Pbbt!
[ Laughter ]
[ Pop! ]
Sss!
[ Quacking ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Slurp! ]
Cornhole it!
[ Laughter and applause ]
How many more you got?
-100.
-Really?
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, roller coasters,
for letting me ride
a line chart.
There you have it, everybody.
Those are
[ Cheering and applause ]
my "Thank You Notes."